The artificial intelligence
arms race is on.
Who will be the first to
achieve full self awareness?
Earlier this week,
Mark Zuckerberg
revealed on an earnings
call that Facebook
has formed an artificial
intelligence group, which
will develop new AI tools using
the vast collection of images
and other data that users
have uploaded to the site.
According to the
project's lead researcher,
the first goal will be to
implement image recognition.
Meaning when you upload
a photo, Facebook
will know, without
you tagging it,
what it is, what's going
on, or even who's in it.
That might sound like
an unexciting use of AI.
But even that
requires a huge amount
of computational power relying
on layers of trial and error
and analyzing an image.
Google already has an
opt-in "find my face"
feature for Google+, though I
haven't seen it used that much
yet.
And on Google Glass,
which would seem
like a natural medium
for face recognition,
that tech is currently banned.
And as a side note,
some designers
are already coming
up with creative ways
to thwart facial
recognition software.
But beyond just image
scanning, the real dream of AI
is to build computers
that work just
like the brain with the
ability to self learn
and to teach itself new tasks.
Google, for example,
is partnering with NASA
on a quantum AI project with
the goal of vastly speeding up
that process.
With that quantum
twist, computers
could analyze visual or
other cues exponentially more
quickly.
But already existing
AI tech is being
used in training simulations
for military and commercial use
where users can program
simulated human agents
to respond autonomously to cues.
And of course, personal
assistants, like Siri,
can respond to our questions,
even if they don't always
get them right, at
least not right now.
And for more on current
advances in robotics,
check out Trace's
video on Valkyrie,
one of the latest
beasts from NASA.
Thanks for watching.
See you next time.